China has defended its growing
partnership with Italy but is it a good
thing criticism coming from the United
States by the way that's after the White
House urged rule not to join Beijing's
belt on road infrastructure project we
view belt and road initiative as a made
by China for China initiative we're
skeptical the Italian government's
endorsement will bring any sustained
economic benefits to the Italian people
and it may end up harming Italy's global
reputation in the long run this position
taken by the US side is laughable as a
major country Italy knows exactly what
policies serve its own interests and it
can make its decisions independently
well Rome is expected to sign up to the
initiative when Chinese President Xi
Jinping visits at the end of the month
at least coalition government they've
also been talking about the benefits one
way for us to increase trade values is
to first increase investment this is
done by these memorandums one belt one
road it is a very fertile area for
investment let's just go through what
we're actually talking about here the
belt and Road initiative sponge three
continents all the way from China to
Europe and Africa upon completion it's
expected to connect nearly two thirds of
the world's population by linking key
cities by roads railways ports Beijing
has pledged 1 trillion dollars in
infrastructure development over the
course of the next decade however the US
has expressed security concerns over the
project and questioned China's motives
sociologist Paulo Bernard Dini
believes Italy has much to gain from the
initiative clearly there is a strong
political crisis between China and the
US and obviously they are taking
advantage of this crisis to act in this
patronizing and frankly little I mean
not so rational way we've Italy asked me
telling us what we have to do our thing
for the benefit of it and also for the
benefit of the entire Mediterranean area
I think will be a great advantage for
economy under on several points of view
we'd be revitalizing the Mediterranean
trader will give new life especially to
two parts the part of Venice and the
part of Trieste
by way of lime
for them away by way of sea and they are
all extremely beneficial for Europe
there will be a new link between them
between the same great continent of
Eurasia and I don't see any potential
damage for the United States economy as
far as I can understand
you